>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
WE OFTEN ACCUSE POLITICIANS OF
DISHONESTY ON THE SHOW.
LET US BOIL IT ON.
NOTHING THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
ADVOCATES FOR HIS MORE DISHONEST
THAN GUN CONTROL.
EVERYTHING IS FALSE.
MOST ACTUALLY AREN'T LIKE THAT.
TRY TO BE HONEST ON THE SHOW.
YOU CAN STILL SORT OF SEE WHAT
THE OTHER SIDE IS TALKING ABOUT.
HE DEEPLY DISLIKED TAXES, BUT
YOU CAN STILL ACKNOWLEDGE IT'S
UNFAIR TO CHARGE PEOPLE FOR THE
SERVICES RECEIVED BY THE
GOVERNMENT.
OR YOU CAN HATE ABORTION AND WE
DO.
AND YOU CAN STILL UNDERSTAND
THAT IF YOU ARE BEING TOTALLY
HONEST ABOUT IT, WHY A SCARED
PREGNANT TEENAGER MIGHT BE
TEMPTED TO HAVE ONE.
BUT GUN CONTROL IS NOT LIKE
THAT.
GUN CONTROL IS ENTIRELY
FRAUDULENT.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY CLAIMS THAT
GUNS CAUSE VIOLENCE.
THAT IS A CORE CLAIM AND IT IS A
LIE.
THE PLACES IN THIS COUNTRY THAT
HAVE THE MOST GUNS AND THE
LOOSEST CONTROLS ON THOSE GUNS
ALSO HAVE THE LEAST GUN
VIOLENCE.
THAT IS THE BOTTOM LINE.
YOU CAN LOOK IT UP.
IT'S PUBLICLY AVAILABLE TO
ANYONE.
ANYONE WHO TRIES TO RESTRICT TO
ILLEGALLY OWN FIREARMS IS NOT
TRYING TO MAKE AMERICA SAFER.
THE POINT IS TO DISARM YOU, TO
STRIP YOU OF YOUR AUTONOMY ON
YOUR RIGHT TO SELF-DEFENSE.
GUN CONTROL IS NOT ABOUT GUNS.
GUN CONTROL IS ABOUT WHO
CONTROLS AMERICA.
IS THAT THE POPULATION AS IN A
DEMOCRACY MR. MARK ORDERS ALL
CONTROL GO TO A SMALL GROUP OF
AUTHORITARIANS AS IN AN
OLIGARCHY?
THOSE ARE THE STAKES IN THE GUN
CONTROL DEBATE.
IT'S NOT ABOUT GUNS.
IT'S ABOUT WHO RUNS THE COUNTRY.
SO, WITH THAT IN MIND,
JOE BIDEN'S SPEECH TODAY CALLING
FOR MORE GUN CONTROL SHOULD MAKE
YOU UNCOMFORTABLE.
ALMOST NOTHING BIDEN SAID WAS
TRUE.
HERE ARE A FEW HIGHLIGHTS TO
GIVE YOU A FLAVOR.
BIDEN CLAIMED THAT FIREARMS
PURCHASED AT GUN SHOWS ARE
EXEMPT FROM BACKGROUND CHECKS.
THAT'S A LIE.
ANYONE WHO HAS EVER BEEN TO A
GUN SHOW CAN SHOW YOU.
JOE BIDEN CLAIMS THAT GUN
MANUFACTURERS HAVE TOTAL
IMMUNITY AGAINST LAWSUITS.
THAT IS ALSO A LIE.
GUN MANUFACTURERS GET SUED ALL
THE TIME.
ASK THEM.
SO, IS THE SPEECH AIMING TO
MISLEAD RATHER THAN INFORMED?
JOE BIDEN WANTED TO REMIND YOU
THAT THOSE RIGHTS ARE NOT REALLY
THE FIRST PLACE.
THEY ARE NOT COME AS HE PUT IT,
ABSOLUTE.
>> NOTHING I AM ABOUT TO
RECOMMEND IN ANY WAY IMPINGES ON
THE SECOND AMENDMENT.
PHONY ARGUMENTS SUGGESTING THAT
THESE ARE SECOND AMENDMENT
RIGHTS AT STAKE WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
BUT NO AMENDMENT, NO AMENDMENT
TO THE CONSTITUTION IS ABSOLUTE.
>> Tucker: YOU HEARD THE
SIRENS IN THE BACKGROUND
RESPONDING TO THE SKYROCKETING
CRIME RATE IN THE CITY IT
RESIDES OVER.
BUT THE RIGHT TO KEEP AND BEAR
ARMS SHALL NOT BE INFRINGED.
THAT'S THE PROMISE IN THE U.S.
CONSTITUTION.
BUT ACCORDING TO JOE BIDEN, IT'S
STILL NOT AN ABSOLUTE RIGHT
DESPITE WHAT THE TEXT SAYS.
NO, THAT RIGHT IS SUBJECT TO HIS
APPROVAL AND HIS INTERPRETATION.
JOE BIDEN'S IN CHARGE OF THE
CONSTITUTION NOW.
JOE BIDEN DEFINES ITS TERMS.
AND JOE BIDEN HAS DECIDED TO
SOMETHING CALLED STABILIZING CAN
NO LONGER BE ALLOWED.
IT IS USED BY TARGET SHOOTERS TO
HOLD HEAVY FIREARMS.
THEY PLAY ZERO ROLE IN THE
MURDER THE MURDER EPIDEMIC NOW
UNDERWAY IN OUR CITIES.
THE WISE JOE BIDEN BANNING THEM
WITHOUT THE APPROVAL OF
CONGRESS?
PROBABLY BECAUSE UP TO
40 MILLION LAW-ABIDING AMERICANS
OWN THIS DEVICE AND UNDER THI
ORDER, JOE BIDEN'S ORDER,
EVERYONE OF THOSE PEOPLE HAVE TO
ALERT FEDERAL AUTHORITIES AND
PAY HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS IN FINES
FOR THE CRIME OF OWNING A
HARMLESS PIECE OF PLASTIC THAT
WAS LEGAL YESTERDAY.
AND IF THEY DON'T COMPLY,
JOE BIDEN'S FEDERAL AUTHORITIES
CAN THEN DRAG THEM OFF IN
HANDCUFFS, USE THE PROPERTY, AND
CHARGE THEM WITH A FELONY.
SO WITH A SINGLE STROKE OF A
PEN, JOE BIDEN JUST TURNED TENS
OF MILLIONS OF OVERWHELMINGLY
REPUBLICAN VOTERS INTO
CRIMINALS.
IS THE STARTING TO MAKE SENSE
NOW?
THINK ABOUT THAT FOR A MINUTE
AND YOU WILL BEGIN TO UNDERSTAND
WHY THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS SO
FOCUSED ON WHAT THEY CALL
WEAPONS OF WAR.
YOU MIGHT KNOW THEM AS A
SEMIAUTOMATIC SMALL CALIBER
SPORTING RIFLES THAT NORMAL
PEOPLE USED FOR HUNTING AND
TARGET SHOOTING AND HOME
DEFENSE.
HERE'S THE THING THAT YOU SHOULD
KNOW.
AND AGAIN, DON'T TAKE OUR WORD
FOR IT.
LOOK IT UP.
NO SUBJECT IS MORE CAREFULLY
CATALOGUED THAN GUNS.
GUNS LIKE THE SCUM OF THE
SO-CALLED WEAPONS OF WAR PLAY NO
MEANINGFUL ROLE IN CRIME.
VIRTUALLY ALL GUN OWNERS HAVE A
HANDGUN.
A SMALL NUMBER OF PEOPLE, AGAIN,
PROVABLE, A SMALL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR MOST
OF THE VIOLENCE AND THEY USE A
SMALL NUMBER OF WEAPONS TO
COMMIT IT.
HERE ARE THE NUMBERS.
ACCORDING TO THE MOST RECENT
DATA FROM THE FBI, FIREARMS WERE
INVOLVED IN A TOTAL OF 10,258
HOMICIDES IN 2019, THE LAST DATE
AVAILABLE.
FEWER THAN 500 WERE COMMITTED
WITH RIFLES INCLUDING WEAPONS OF
WAR.
SO, CRIMINALS DON'T USE RIFLES.
THEY ARE NOT CONCEALABLE.
MAYBE THAT'S WHY.
IN FACT, MORE PEOPLE WERE
MURDERED WITH KNIVES THAN WITH
RIFLES.
SO, IF YOU ACTUALLY CARED ABOUT
MAKING THE COUNTRY SAFER COMIC
KEEPING PEOPLE FROM GETTING
MURDERED, YOU WOULD TARGET
HANDGUNS IN BIG CITIES.
THAT IS WHERE THE MURDERS ARE.
THAT IS WHERE THE VIOLENCE IS.
BUT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
DOING THE OPPOSITE OF THIS.
THE MIRROR IMAGE OF THIS.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
LETTING BIG-CITY CRIMINALS GO.
PEOPLE WHO USE GUNS FOR VIOLENCE
ARE WALKING OUT OF JAIL.
INSTEAD, THE BIDEN DEMONSTRATION
IS USING, YOU SAW IT TODAY, THE
FULL FORCE OF GOVERNMENT TO
DISARM PEACEFUL VOTERS AND
ZIP CODE VOTERS WHO VOTED FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
IT IS THAT SIMPLE.
TODAY, BIDEN ANNOUNCED THAT HE
WANTS TO BAN WHAT HE CALLS
"ASSAULT WEAPONS."
HE IS SPEAKING ABOUT THEY ARE
15, WHICH OF THE SINGLE MOST
POPULAR SPORTING RIFLE IN
AMERICA.
SO, THE POINT IS IF THEY BAN
SO-CALLED ASSAULT WEAPONS, WITH
THE COUNTRY BECOME SAFER?
THAT IS THE ONLY QUESTION THAT
MATTERS.
WE DON'T NEED TO GET TO THE
ANSWER BECAUSE WE HAVE TRIED
THIS BEFORE.
UNDER BILL CLINTON, FOR TEN FULL
YEARS, HE BANNED ASSAULT RIFLES.
AND THAT MY LAW, THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE SAW THE EFFECT.
SO WE KNOW THE EFFECT.
YOU CAN LOOK IT UP IF YOU WANT.
IT DIDN'T WORK.
ONCE THAT BAN EXPIRED IN 2004,
GUN HOMICIDES FELL IN ALMOST
EVERY MAJOR CITY.
SO, POLICIES LIKE THIS ONE ARE
UNHINGED FROM REALITY TO PUT IT
GENTLY.
SO, TO ENFORCE THEM, JOE BIDEN
HAS NOMINATED A MAN WHO IS
UNHINGED FROM REALITY.
HIS NAME IS DAVID CHIPMAN HE
WILL NOW RUN TOBACCO AND
FIRE ALARMS.
AN AGENCY THAT JOE BIDEN
REFERRED TO AS AFC.
>> TODAY AM PROUD TO NOMINATE
DAVID CHIPMAN TO SERVE AS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE AFT.
DAVID KNOWS AFT WELL.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
HILARIOUS.
IF YOU ARE JOE BIDEN, AFT IS THE
TEACHERS UNION.
SO, WHO IS DAVID CHIPMAN?
WELL, HE IS A CONSPIRACY NUT.
HE CLAIMS THAT IT SHOT DOWN
HELICOPTERS DURING A WACO SIEGE
IN 1993.
NO, IT DIDN'T.
NO ONE WAS SHOT OR INJURED THAT
DAY.
THE HELICOPTERS DO NOT CRASH.
THAT IS A BIZARRE CLAIM TO ME
FOR SOMEONE WHO IS DIRECTLY
INVOLVED IN THE CASE, AS DAVID
CHIPMAN WAS.
BUT IT'S WORSE THAN THAT.
IN 1993, THE ATF KILLED DOZENS
OF INNOCENT CHILDREN AND AT
LEAST ONE PREGNANT WOMAN FOR NO
OBVIOUS REASON.
IT IS ONE OF THE WORST THINGS
THAT FEDERAL AGENTS HAVE EVER
DONE IN THIS COUNTRY.
SO IF YOU ARE TAKING OVER THE
ATF, MAYBE YOU COULD APOLOGIZE
FOR THAT.
BUT NO, HE LIED ABOUT IT AND
THEN --
ATTACKING THE VICTIMS FORGETTING
SYPHILIS.
IT WAS NOT EVIDENCE OF A
GENEROUS SPIRIT.
IT WAS EVIDENCE OF ZEALOUS.
THIS IS THE MAN THAT JOE BIDEN
HAS NOMINATED TO LEAD ATF.
BUT IT GETS WORSE THING ON THAT.
HE SUGGESTED THAT PEOPLE WHO
FAILED BACKGROUND CHECKS SHOULD
BE ARRESTED ON THE SPOT.
WHILE AT ATF, I CONDUCTED
STUDIES INVOLVING PEOPLE WHO
CONDUCTED --
THIS IS A PERFECT OPPORTUNITY TO
ARREST PEOPLE BEFORE COMMITTING
CRIMES RATHER THAN RESPONDING
AFTER THE FACT.
ARREST PEOPLE BEFORE THEY COMMIT
CRIMES.
THAT IS A BRAND-NEW CONCEPT IN
AMERICAN LAW, THAT THE CHINESE
ARE HIGHLY FAMILIAR WITH.
BUT THE SUGGESTION DOES RAISE A
POINT TO THE JOE BIDEN FAMILY.
HE JUST APPOINTED A GUY WHO
THINKS THAT PEOPLE RELY ON
FEDERAL BACKGROUND CHECKS SHOULD
GO TO PRISON.
DO YOU KNOW ANY?
HE LIED ON A FEDERAL BACKGROUND
CHECK.
THAT IS NOT SPECULATION.
HE DID.
WE HAVE SEEN THE FORM.
SO THE QUESTION IS, WILL HE
ARREST THE PRESIDENT'S SON?
AND IF HE DOESN'T ARREST THE
PRESIDENT'S SON, THE QUESTION IS
HOW EXACTLY ARE YOU OBLIGATED TO
FOLLOW THESE RULES?
HOW CAN YOU PARTICIPATE IN A
SYSTEM LIKE THAT?
AGAIN, SINCERE QUESTION.
THEY SHOULD EXPLAIN.
WE SHOULD NOTE THAT DAVID
CHIPMAN HAS SAID A LOT OF OTHER
THINGS ON THE INTERNET THAT
HASN'T WANT YOU TO SEE.
HE BLOCKED HIS TWITTER ACCOUNT
SO THAT NOBODY CAN READ IT.
THE DAILY WIRE FOUND AN ARCHIVE
VERSION.
THEY FOUND THAT DAVID CHIPMAN
HAS DELETED AT LEAST A THOUSAND
TWEETS IN RECENT DAYS AND WE CAN
ONLY SPECULATE ABOUT WHAT HE
SAID.
WE DO KNOW THAT WHAT HE SAID
PUBLICLY TELLS US ALL WE NEED TO
KNOW ABOUT HOW HE GOT THIS JOB.
IN OCTOBER 2018, FOR EXAMPLE,
DAVID CHIPMAN TOLD THE HILL THAT
AR-15s IT SHOULD BE TREATED
"JUST LIKE MACHINE GUNS."
WELL, MACHINE GUNS ARE BANNED IN
THIS COUNTRY.
HE BELIEVES THE SINGLE MOST
POPULAR RENTAL IN AMERICA SHOULD
BE BANNED.
HE MADE THAT REMARK IN THE PAST.
IN 2012, HE SUGGESTED TO MSNBC
THAT THE SECRET SERVICE SHOULD
NOT CARRY FIREARMS AND LAST
YEAR, DAVID CHIPMAN OPENLY
MOCKED MILLIONS OF AMERICANS WHO
WERE BUYING TO PROTECT THEIR
FAMILIES FROM THE CRIME WAVE
THAT HIS PARTY HAS UNLEASHED ON
THE COUNTRY.
>> THEY MAY THINK THAT THEY ARE
DIEHARD, READY TO GO, BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THEY ARE PUTTING
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES
AND DANGERS.
BUT I WOULD SUGGEST IS FOR THOSE
PEOPLE WHO ARE FIRST-TIME GUN
OWNERS, THAT THEY DID GO OUT
AND BUY A GUN, I WOULD SECURE
THAT GUN LOCKED AND HIDE IT
BEHIND THE CANS OF BEEF JERKY
STORED IN THE CABINET AND ONLY
BRING THAT OUT IF THE ZOMBIES
START TO APPEAR.
AND I DON'T THINK THEY ARE.
>> Tucker: IT'S HARD TO
IMAGINE A REMARK THAT IS MORE
INFERIOR RATING THAN THAT ONE.
IF YOU BROUGHT DOWN MIKE BOUGHT
A GUN TO PROTECT YOUR FAMILY,
YOUR BUSINESS, YOUR HOME DURINGT
THESE PEOPLE UNLEASHED ON THE
COUNTRY, A CONSPIRACY NOT
RUNNING THE ATF CALLS YOU CRAZY,
THAT IS WHY IF YOU MADE THE
MISTAKE OF BUYING A HANDGUN WITH
A MAGAZINE THAT HOLDS MORE THAN
TEN ROUNDS, IN OTHER WORDS IF
YOU OWN ONE OF THE MOST POPULAR
GUNS IN AMERICA, YOU WOULD BE
OBLIGATED TO SURRENDER TO THAT
GUY.
>> HIGH-CAPACITY MEANS, WHAT
KIND OF NUMBERS I WAS TALKING
ABOUT?
>> YEAH, SO I THINK THE
CONSENSUS HAS BEEN AROUND 10.
AND THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
REASONS WHY --
>> 10 AND ABOVE WOULD BE HIGH
CUSTOMER >> YEAH, LET'S
SAY 10 AND BELOW WOULD BE REASO.
ABOVE WOULD BE REGULATED.
>> Tucker: SO, THIS RAISES A
LOT OF QUESTIONS.
WHY IS DAVID CHIPMAN ALLOWED TO
DECIDE HOW MANY ROLLOUT?
IS HE IN CHARGE OF PROTECTING
YOUR FAMILY?
DOES HE LIVE IN YOUR
NEIGHBORHOOD?
ARE YOUR CHILDREN HIS
RESPONSIBILITY?
THIS IS OUTRAGEOUS.
BUT WORSE THAN THAT, IT'S NOT
REAL.
PEOPLE LIKE DAVID CHIPMAN ART
OPPOSED TO GUN VIOLENCE.
IN FACT, PEOPLE LIKE DAVID
CHIPMAN AND HIS PARTY CERTAINLY
ARE MAKING GUN VIOLENCE POSSIBLE
IN THIS COUNTRY.
WE COULD GIVE YOU MANY EXAMPLES
WE HAVE FOR YEARS PEER HERE IS A
NEW ONE.
IN WASHINGTON, THE CITY IS
PLANNING TO STOP ENFORCING GUN
LAWS.
REALLY?
THE PARTY THAT THINKS GUNS CAUSE
VIOLENCE IS NO LONGER PULLING
THEM OFF THE STREETS.
HE JUST SENT A MEMO ANNOUNCING
"NO LONGER ARE WE FOCUSED ON
GETTING GUNS."
ARE THEY TELLING YOU THAT YOUR
GUNS ARE THE PROBLEM?
NOT A CRIMINAL'S GUN.
YOUR GUNS.
BECAUSE YOU ARE THE CRIMINAL
NOW.
MEANWHILE, IN CHICAGO WHERE A
20-MONTH-OLD CHILD WAS JUST SHOT
ON THE STREET LAST MONTH,
MAYOR HAS DECIDED THAT NOT ALL
GUNS NEED TO BE REMOVED.
ACCORDING TO LORI LIGHTFOOT, IT
IS "MILITARY GRADE WEAPONS FROM
OTHER STATES."
>> TUESDAY, LITTLE KAYDEN WAS
SHOT ON LAKESHORE DRIVE.
18 OTHERS WERE SHOT.
5 OF THEM DIED.
WEDNESDAY, MAYOR LORI LIGHTFOOT
SAID PART OF THE CRIME ISSUE IS
GUN CONTROL.
>> IF YOU CAN GO OVER TO THE
BORDER AND LITERALLY BUY
MILITARY GRADE WEAPONS AT ANY
QUANTITY.
>> NUMBER SHOW THAT CRIME IS UP.
AROUND THIS TIME LAST YEAR,
THERE WERE 521 PEOPLE SHOT.
NOW THAT NUMBER 743.
>> Tucker: THIS IS ONE OF
THOSE TOPICS THAT IS HARD TO DO
ON TV.
BECAUSE IN ABOUT AN HOUR, YOU
CAN LEARN MORE ABOUT THIS TOPIC.
ACTUAL FACTS ABOUT THIS TOPIC
THAT EVERY SINGLE PERSON MAKING
THE POLICY.
EVERYTHING THEY SAY IS UNTRUE
AND PROVABLY SO.
THERE IS NO ISSUE WHICH THEY
MINED MORE THAN THIS ONE.
LORI LIGHTFOOT, THE ONE THAT YOU
JUST SAW.
CHICAGO'S OWN DATA PROVES IT.
ACCORDING TO CHICAGO POLICE IN
2018, 2019, AUTHORITIES
ENCOUNTERED A GRAND TOTAL OF --
4 PEOPLE IN THE WHOLE CITY WITH
RIFLES.
THAT'S IT.
AND THAT IS WHAT LORI LIGHTFOOT
IS FOCUSED ON.
IN THAT SAME PERIOD, THEY
ENCOUNTERED 44 PEOPLE WITH
REVOLVERS.
32 PEOPLE WIELDING THEIR FEET IN
A VIOLENT MANNER.
AND THE REST, OF COURSE WERE
SEMIAUTOMATIC HANDGUNS.
THAT'S ALL THE MURDERS AND
EVERYONE KNOWS IT.
RIFLES ARE NOT A REAL THREAT IN
CHICAGO AND HAVEN'T BEEN FOR A
LONG TIME, IF EVER.
BETWEEN 2013 AND 2016, JUST 4.8%
OF GUNS WERE COVERED BY THE
CHICAGO POLICE PEERED 4.8%.
THE MOST RECENT MURDER REPORT
FROM CHICAGO WAS FROM ALL THE
WAY BACK IN 2011.
BUT ACCORDING TO THAT REPORT,
JUST ONE RIFLE WAS USED IN A
HOMICIDE IN THE CITY OF CHICAGO.
ONE.
AND THAT IS WHAT THEY WANT TO
TAKE AWAY.
WHY?
BECAUSE YOU OWN IT, NOT THE
CRIMINALS.
IN THE DECADES THAT FOLLOW, KIM
FOX TOOK OVER IN CHICAGO AND
DURING HER TENURE, PROSECUTORS
STARTED DROPPING CASES FOR
SERIOUS GUN CRIMES.
NOT ACCIDENTALLY BUT AS A MATTER
OF POLICY.
RECKLESS DISCHARGE OF A FIREARM,
AGGRAVATED DISCHARGE, SERIOUS
CRIMES INVOLVING GUNS.
THEY DROPPED THE CHARGES.
THEY ARE NOT WORRIED ABOUT GUN
CRIMES.
THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT YOU
PROTECTING YOURSELF.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
CRIMINALS WHO COMMIT VIOLENT
CRIMES ARE GOING FREE.
MEANWHILE, YOU HAVEN'T HEARD
ANYONE.
YOU HAVEN'T DONE ANYTHING WRONG.
BUT SUDDENLY YOU ARE A FELON FOR
TRYING TO DEFEND YOUR HOME.
YOU CAN SEE WHA